my dear brothers and sisters there's two
ways to defend the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam the first way
the the the first method is to defend
him against the disbelievers from
outside the other method to defend him
and guess the Muslims who tried to
corrupt his teaching from within and
when we advise the Muslims or correct
the Muslims who try to distort the
teaching of the Prophet Muhammad we're
not doing it to mock the Muslim or to
belittle the Muslim rather we're doing
it for the sake to preserve the teaching
of Islam likewise what happens to
Christians in the past because they did
not defend and protect the religion of
Jesus from within so what happened it
became corrupted so we have to defend
Islam and the teacher of the Prophet
Muhammad from the enemies from outside
and those from within Islam those who
try to restores and corrupt the teaching
of our beloved prophet
sincerity and knowledge